επισημηθέση για ν ποσφέρεις πλά το λέω επειδή πολ ου τελετο τελευταίο διά ίνα πολλές
τα ανιφορές που ακούστηκε το όνομα της για συγκεκριμένο υπουργίο αλλά τελευταία στιγμή κάτι δεν
γίνο εντάξει αυτό ο δυστυχώς να το πάμε πίσω στον εθρό σταύρο φαίνετε ότε αγκαλιάζεται
και από τους νέους αρκετά σας χαρωποι αυτό ότι είναοι πλέω μπορεί να τους σεσαο
ικάνοτυς κατηγορούν ότι εναι επάνω στα κινητά συνέχεια και στα τάπλετα αλλά φαίνετα ότι έχουν
και ώραμα και όρεξη να δουλέψουν σε ότι απρτα θελανθρωποία σίγουρα ο εληθός στραβώς έχει
το τμημα νέο τόσα χόνια ίμαστε από ταλίες οργανώσεις που έγιχαμε ξεκινήσει με τους νέους
και διότι πρέπει να μάθεις τρα πεδιά να ποσφέγουν τον εθελοντισμό και τ μεμα νέον
έχει συνεγρασία με το υποίον παιδίας και τα παιδιάπηγαίνουν και κδνυν και διαλέξει στα σχολία
με διαφοράςσ δημοτικό με διαφοραπειχνίδιαποσπαθούν να μάθον τα στα παιδίά να πεγάσουν τη το νόημα
του εθελοντισμού μετά στο γυμνάσιο με άλλες με άλλον τοπωστε να να μάθουν τα παιδιά
ότι μπορούν προσφέουν και να βοηθήσουν το συνάθωπο τους και πιστεύονται πάρα πολύ σημαντικό είναι
τα παιδιά του θαβά του που έχουνται τον ριθώ σταυρο το σαβατο και βοηθούν και
γαχουνδικάπουλί προγράμματα γιπου είναι γιακίνους και λιοθετούνητιίδρημα είτα τους μαθαίνουν διάφορα πράβατα επιστεύε ότι επολύ
σημαντικό είναι να ενδιαφεύονται ιότι έτσι σιγά σιγά μαθαίνουν και μεγαλώνοντας εκείνη θα αναλάβουν θνα
κλεισω ρωτώντας σασκυνέβων εδοπουλ